o pessoal é normalmente quando as
pessoas me vêem eles vêem uma mulher
a imagem da mulher que construiu uma
carreira empresa de tecnologia chegou
cio
eu costumo dizer que esse é o topo 2 do
iceberg
mas o interessante mesmo é a construção
desse caminho empreendedor que me trouxe
até aqui é isso que eu vou compartilhar
com vocês
começou muito cedo para uma criança
inconformada
é ela inconformada com tudo que me
faltava lhe faltava amor não faltava
carinho mas me faltavam bens materiais
que me faziam ser excluída de um grupo
social que era muito importante para mim
que era a escola e alguns acontecimentos
eram muito marcante para mim eu lembro
de um desfile de 7 de setembro em que eu
queria participar mas sei que tem uma
634 branca e eu não tinha meus pais
muito humildes não tinham condições de
comprar aquele me a minha em
conformidade queria eu queria mesmo
participar a cadeia num jeito meu
inconformismo também levou a buscar
outras alternativas para fazer o que eu
queria mas eu queria pertencer a
pertencer àquele grupo é acionar minha
capacidade intelectual e resolvi ser a
sedf da turma quem sabe né aí eu vou
fazer parte desse grupo c d f da turma é
bom pra quem professor
a turma não gosta de cdf na minha turma
de um cdf
eu então quem como é que eu ia
participar desse grupo eu aprendi desde
muito cedo que construí a minha carreira
não seria uma coisa fácil mas aos 12
anos eu me tornei dependente
financeiramente fazia várias coisas para
mim vir a nova calçada cuidava de uma
criança fazer uma faxina tinha o meu
dinheiro e começou a minha carreira lhe
de independência carreira foi
interrompida aos 16 anos
aos 16 anos eu engravidei e teve um
filho
só que os pais muito humildes muito
simples achavam que engravidou tem que
casar contra a minha vontade eu aceitei
um casamento e me tornei mãe foi a
melhor escola que durou dois anos pra
mim meu filho é colocou dentro de mim um
pouco mais
for mesmo eu sabia que eu queria dois
anos depois eu me separei do pai dele e
ele veio a falecer num acidente então
literalmente ficou eu e meu filho não
podia mais viver de qualquer coisa
fazendo um trabalho no outro eu
precisava de um trabalho efetivo
foi o que eu sempre procuro emprego de
urgência agência eu recebi uma indicação
e fui pra minha primeira empresa
minha primeira empresa cheguei lá pra
fazer o processo seletivo ea pessoa que
me entrevistou falou o seguinte olha não
sei se você vai ficar aqui porque as
mulheres entram em sites e em todos os
homens e os funcionários todos os homens
elas se envolvem acaba não dando certo
me empolgou muito eu saí dali olhei pra
frente daquele prédio pensei não vou
voltar aqui nunca mais não só voltei
confiei 17 anos
ali sim começa a minha carreira
empreendedora que é muito legal entre na
recepção e e galguei aí quase que um
plano de carreira que eu fui pro
administrativo financeiro da empresa
funções uma conformidade combinava
comigo é eu queria fazer mais pela
empresa eu queria ver aquela empresa
crescer
eu queria crescer junto com ela e
precisa fazer alguma coisa
pensei quero fazer negócios e fechar
negócios da empresa
a ousadia da criança que era surpresa
pra mim e eu resolvi colar nos
engenheiros e desenvolvedores para que
pudesse aprender um pouco mais o produto
é uma empresa desenvolver software para
engenharia
eu fiz uma faculdade de engenharia da
empresa
eu atendia os clientes com tanta
propriedade transformava aquelas é
aquele informações técnicas e técnico
para negócio e vendia para os clientes
comecei a fazer negócios lá nessa função
administrativo financeiro
só que eu queria realmente e para a área
de negócios e eles estavam tão
acostumadas comigo a cuidar daquele
menininho que não queria me deixar voar
e tudo que eu queira fazer isso
comecei a sacrificar os meus horários de
folga almoço às vezes conseguia ficar um
pouco
além do trabalho para fechar negócios e
mostrar resultado e conquistar aquele
espaço porque já sabia que ia ser bom
para a empresa e eles não conseguiam ver
aquilo aquela empresa já era minha e eu
falei que não seria fácil conquistar o
meu caminho
eu pedi pra ir pra área de negócios em
um dos dias
um dos diretores falou não não é você
vai ficar aqui falar um monte de caixa
para despachar vai faturar vai fazer
trabalho não conseguia perceber eu
peguei uma casa daquela de um chute
revoltada porque não queria que olhem eu
sabia o que eu queria saber que eu podia
ser melhor ali dá resultado da empresa
aí no dia seguinte ele me chama e falou
tudo bem tu queres ir para a área
comercial pode só que não tem volta
se não der certo já vai ter alguém aqui
no teu lugar e simplesmente não tem
volta tudo bem tudo bem estava preparada
ninguém tinha me capacitado sabia que eu
podia
fui para a área de negócios não deu
outra eu tinha uma produtividade três
vezes maior do que as pessoas que já
estavam ali eu tinha tanto conhecimento
comigo e eu já armazenava esse
conhecimento que não me preocupava e
repassar esse conhecimento adiante e
comecei a capacitar trocar e treinar
aquela equipe que estava lá
não demorou muito tempo eu me tornei
gerente daquela área
ali eu precisava agora além dos
conhecimentos técnicos e do produto só
conheci gente porque eu entendia que a
empresa precisava de outras pessoas para
multiplicar aquilo que eu já fazia e
comecei a participar de processos de de
eventos de rh para entender um pouco
melhor como é que a gente recruta
pessoas que se adéquam o nosso projecto
que compra o nosso projeto que faz
diferença e uma psicóloga resolveu fazer
um teste com a minha equipe
os melhores da minha equipe tinha
algumas características muito
semelhantes
a partir dali comecei a recrutar pessoas
com perfis parecidos
isso deu muito certo aumento muito
assertividade das contratações e eu
formei um time de 40 pessoas
até hoje chamado time de águas
só que essas 40 pessoas elas elas eram
mulheres e por que mulher
elas comprarão aquele projeto tanto
quanto eu tinha uma empresa como delas e
elas não reluta vão estabelecer contato
elas vendiam por telefone uma venda
técnica elas conseguiam usar a
imaginação para demonstrar um produto
técnico para quem estava do outro lado
da linha
elas eram incansáveis e elas davam
resultados muito maiores do que os
homens
e se aquela empresa era a minha eu tinha
que focar em que me dava melhor
resultado e aí foi uma seleção natural
foram mulheres
mas eu não acho que ter sucesso é uma
questão de gênero de verdade eu tenho
grandes exemplos masculinos na minha
vida profissional eu costumo dizer que
muitas vezes eu tenho que acessar dentro
de mim uma força masculina né e é
questão de ter coragem para ser o melhor
é questão de encarar a coragem é uma
coisa que tem que acontecer eu costumo
dizer que eu não tenho medo e foi isso e
assim que eu penso então não é uma
questão de gênero de verdade
só que até ali já tinha experiência
profissional e eu não tinha feito uma
faculdade ea empresa eu pensei que iam
fazer a faculdade de administração já
conheço do financeiro da recepção de
negócio administração para conseguir
trabalhar melhor a empresa agregar mais
valor à empresa lá fui eu por uma
faculdade de administração faculdade e
suas conformidade que não combina comigo
não fazer se leva com a barriga estudar
rapidinho fazem qualquer jesus
eu sabia que eu queria eu estava lá em
busca de conhecimento para poder aplicar
na empresa e já no meu primeiro 1º a
primeira fase da faculdade eu fui fazer
um trabalho eu fiz um trabalho a
pesquisa super dedicada apresenta esse
trabalho estava acostumado a falar em
público tinha domínio certo domínio de
palco e eu simplesmente fiz o trabalho
de um banho o professor amor e o
professor saiu da sala
lembra daquelas edf nesse dia eu li
geralmente quase fui linchada
eu tinha 33 anos eles 18 eu tinha
aumentado muito o nível de exigência do
professor pra eles e não tinha me dado
conta foi detestado adianta naquele
mesmo momento sair dali psi que estou
fazendo aqui é preciso que durou cinco
segundo esse pensamento é lógico que eu
preciso me adaptei a eles me tornei
parceira trocava com eles tudo o que eu
podia por trabalho conhecimento material
pra que a gente pudesse fazer um
trabalho colaborativo e eu atingi meu
objetivo super focada sabia que eu
queria e além disso eu trocava de roupa
pra faculdade e pra aparecer como ele eu
tirava a roupa de gerente voltava uma
roupa de estudante e assim eu fiz a
faculdade em quatro anos e conquistei
aquela turma como conquistei minha
equipe interna e com muita verdade com
muita determinação foi conquistando os
sims da minha vida e logo em seguida a
faculdade mexeu com a minha cabeça como
mexe com muita gente e eu pensei só uma
experiência profissional
por mais que eu tenha de me desenvolvido
muito tempo daquela empresa e
desenvolvido empresa junto comigo
precisava de mais uma e daí a empresa
que estou hoje que também é uma empresa
de tecnologia de hardware me procurou e
eu resolvi encarar o desafio
saí de uma gerência de negócios por uma
diretoria de negócios de uma empresa
menor pra poder ter outra empresa minha
outro projeto meu outro propósito ali
muito interessante conseguir elevar os
níveis de faturamento da empresa de uma
forma incrível com uma equipe em coma
equipe boa não sozinha e consegue fazer
parte de outros projetos da empresa
levando a empresa crescendo com a
empresa e fazendo com que a empresa se
desenvolvesse também é é pois de oito
anos aqui me torne se o conhecimento e
reconhecimento pela minha dedicação e
por e por tornar esse espaço meu e
colaborativa com as pessoas que estavam
junto comigo
é o que eu vejo de importante nesse
momento
é esse essa vontade de fazer diferente
de fazer diferente tem um projeto como
sendo seu tem o mesmo propósito
isso pode ser dentro de uma empresa pode
ser formando uma empresa nova
não importa a diferença que a gente
consegue exercer é que vai fazer com que
a gente chegue a um determinado a uma
determinada carreira quer sol ou não eu
digo que essa força interna todas as
pessoas podem acessar e depende só de
nós
eu levei 25 anos para fazer isso vocês
podem pensar que é uma trajetória longa
talvez até seja foi o tempo que eu
consegui fazer mas eu não perdi o foco
não perdi a direção e nenhum sentido o
tempo só foi um pouco mais longo
a geração nova nós trabalhamos muito com
eles que essa geração millenium tem
pressa de crescer ea gente consegue
fazer isso também dentro das empresas
as empresas estabelecidas precisam de
empreendedores tanto quanto precisamos
de novas empresas nascendo então é eu
fui sim uma criança inconformada
eu sou uma adulta inconformada
isso me levou onde eu estou e vocês
escolheram o quê
[Aplausos]